So when you look at tools for
email automation,
there are several platforms you can use.
A lot of start ups use send
grid which is a real cheap and
effective way to send lots
of emails that are custom.
And you don't have to get into a lot
of heavy architecture installation
to get it done, it can get up and
running pretty quickly.
When you get bigger and become a larger
company you can go to things like
responses Marketo That are much larger,
much heavier integration.
They allow a lot of other things that
will let you do targeting, re-targeting,
segmentation that SENDGRID won't do.
So it really depends on where you
are in your company's life cycle and
how many emails you do have.
One of the best ways to generate an
email list is to get them to engage with
your contacts on their own.
If you do that, there's already a level
of trust they've given you because
they've said I like your product, I
like your content, I like your company.
If you don't do that and
you go and purchase a list, there's
a high likelihood they're probably
not going to customers that
are in your target segment.
They're going to unsubscribe and
you're going to be wasting your time and
your money.
So there are several ways you can get
someone to subscribe to your website.
Usually when you come to a blog,
like www.ask-you.com/blog.
What we do is we pop up a little box and
it says want to hear
more from us click here.
And it's really an email address and
a submit button.
It's clean, it's simple, and
it's a great way to get them to
continue to engage with your content.
Another way is when you have a sign up
process again that you'd ask the one
thing we do is you have to sign up for
our content and for our courses.
So to consume a course you have
to give us an email address,
your first name, and last name.
That allows us to understand
what you're interested in and
communicate with you just about
the topics that you want to hear from.
So the biggest component
of email marketing that
marketers need to realize is the fact
that when someone gives you your email,
they're trusting you with that.
It's a very personal thing,
it's very similar to your phone.
So you're letting someone contact
you whenever they want to.
You've established a bond and
trust with that customer.
You will break that trust
by over emailing them or
quote unquote spamming them.
What you really don't want to do is hit
them too often with the wrong message.
You will increase that trust and
they will talk about you and
refer you to other people
if you actually maintain
a good relationship with them and send
them emails they want when they want.
The more you send them things they don't
want, the higher likelihood they'll
unsubscribe from what you do and
not talk with you ever again.
There's a great example of this if
you look at the emails I've gotten
recently from Apple.
They really only send you something
when a new proctor feature is announced,
which is great because I don't see
400 emails from Apple in my stream.
Another example is a consumer grades
company where I get emails from them
probably daily.
I subscribed once but i never subscribed
to get something from them everyday.
It took me about three,
four weeks before I gave up on them and
I don't subscribe anywhere else.
Email marketing is a set of activities
that you take to engage with your
audience to get to come to your site
directly, these are things like
blog posts, social posts,
things on Facebook,LinkedIn and Twitter.
That you engage directly
with your audience and
get them to come to your site.
You really don't want to send the same
person the same message multiple times.
The best thing to do is
to create a theme or
a message that relates to a certain
thing you're trying to promote.
And make that custom.
So for example when you
talk about Fourth of July.
You know messaging around that holiday.
That would promote your product in
conjunction with what's happening
at the time.
Timely messages are extremely important
in getting someone to read it.
The more timely your message is there's
a higher likely that them actually
opening your email and
engaging with your product and company.